Das parkett ist quasi
Die parallelwelt des internets in der man anonym oder unter kaufen kann und zudem ist
Aber nicht ganz so leicht ist zugang zu bekommen ein bisschen tricky überlebenswichtig beispielsweise für menschenrechtler journalisten und widerständler in ländern wie syrien
Oder china doch am tag netten tummeln sich natürlich auch viele kriminelle hacker oder drogenhändler
Beispielsweise doch, wie genau funktioniert es und wie illegal ist, dass das land tatsächlich, warum halten es viele für das vorbild des herkömmlichen internet
Dass wir alle täglich nutzen, ihr habt euch dieses spannende thema bei whatsapp gewünschte bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts. Herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Tja, und jetzt so was kommt und damit man kennt das der vater am ende des videos grob gesagt ist
das parkett
Das dunkle netz an technisch abgeschöpft das netz dieser schutz kann technisch gesehen auf verschiedene art und weise ermöglicht werden doch in der praxis
funktioniert das darknet über die
Anonymisierungs software namens tor wirklich gesehen, quasi, eine art tarnumhang, die amerikanische non profit organisation
Also, tor project hat dafür einen kostenlosen browser entwickelt
Der internetnutzer unkenntlich macht und anonymisiert auch die identität
Der bug labs seitenbetreiber mit der endung onion, die werden verschleiert, die seiten des staates können von den herkömmlichen browsern, wie firefox
Oder google chrome nicht gefunden werden genauso wenig, wie die von den suchmaschinen
Die wir täglich nutzen und obwohl es das dagegen schon länger gibt
Es ist für geheimdienste
Wissenschaftler und so weiter und so fort immer noch schwierig seine strukturen und die nutzer und nutzerinnen zu erforschen und zu analysieren
So weiß man beispielsweise gar nicht genau, wie groß es überhaupt ist denn die adressen werden
Automatisiert erstellt und auch über die anzahl, der bug netznutzer weiß man kaum etwas, was aber klar ist
dass zagreb wird oft als der untergrund des internets bezeichnet in
Ermittlerkreisen heißt es mittlerweile, dass man hier verbrechen als dienstleistung bekommt crime, es ist 12
also
Es geht um drogen und waffenhandels falschgeld und auch im cyber angriffe in einer studie aus dem jahr 2016 hat ein
britisches forschungsteam analysiert in welchem umfang
Das darknet tatsächlich für illegale zwecke genutzt wird rund 5000 an ihren seiten haben sie für ihre untersuchungen durchforstet
Die hälfte der seiten war allerdings leer
Die seiten mit inhalten die gehört 57 in die rubrik illegal
43 prozent
Der seiten dagegen stufte das forschungsteam als legal ein
Der britische studien ging es bei etwa einem viertel der illegal eingestuften inhalte um drogen und beim fünftel der inhalte um illegale finanzgeschäfte
Also, beispielsweise um den handel mit kreditkartendaten und falschgeld und der illegale handel im dax sind unterscheidet sich gar nicht so sehr vom legal hier
Im normalen internet, es gibt verhaftet, die via gps und ein rückgaberecht bezahlt wird allerdings mit crypto währungen
wie bitcoins zurück zur britischen studie um terroristische hetze und
Dem aufruf von gewalt ging es bei neun prozent der inhalte und um verbotene pornografie bei 8 prozent
Der seiten in die studie
Also, zeigt ist längst nicht alles was im netz zu finden ist illegal und so gibt es auch immer wieder stimmen
Die sich für das parkett einsetzen und seine positiven seiten hervorheben unter anderem der chaos computer. Club ccc
deutschlands der sich beispielsweise
2016 dazu geäußert hat nach dem amoklauf in münchen wurde das dach netz jahr von extrem von deutschen behörden kritisiert
Denn der täter soll sich
Die waffe über das mag net organisiert haben dazu der sprecher des ccc - neumann
Das bedrohungsszenario sagt von deutschen behörden gezeichnet wird ist nicht sehr
Realistisch der waffen- und drogenhandel in der realen welt, sei deutlich größer
Als im darknet zudem betont ccc auch immer wieder das schaden und nutzen des st agnes abzuwägen seien für menschen in ländern wie der türkei
Syrien, oder dem iran sei das segment unheimlich wichtig um menschenleben zu schützen und die freiheiten der demokratie zu bewahren
Oder zu erlangen ursprünglich wurde
Das ist eine tatsächlich auch genau zu diesem zweck entwickelt nämlich um dissidenten und dissidentin zu schützen
Die darauf angewiesen waren sich zu informieren und zu veröffentlichen und zwar
Anonymen und ccc-sprecher neunmal geht noch sogar weiter und sagt, dass nach netz ist das internet
Wie man sich eigentlich wünschen würde ein netz ohne zensur und -überwachung mit all seinen vor und nachteilen
Und jetzt noch kurz zu den legalen seiten, des darkness die sehr auch gibt, da gibt es quasi
alles, was ihr euch so vorstellen können blogs über politik katzen technik nerd kam und eine menge tutorials, außerdem gibt es anonyme messenger und
Tausche dienste seit 2010 hat auf facebook einen dort präsenz einige medienhäuser
Wie die washington post haben auch anonyme postfächer über das dach nennt eingerichtet so kommen die redaktion an
Die brisanten nachrichten von whistleblowern, wenn er also auch dabei sein wollt, der link zum tor browser, der ist unten in der video beschreibung
Wenn er als erstes neues zu den themen cyberkrieg verbrechen, im internet partner und kryptographie und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
Dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp, dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video und zwar täglich garantiert
Ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion vor krieg zu machen und mit themen vorschlagen an
Abstimmungen teilnehmen und so weiter und so fort
Und zur begrüßung habe ich noch ein kleines goodie einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen, hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken, die größte
Cyberattacke aller zeit ansonsten, bis dann
Bleibt dran?